DAN SIMON (NARRATING): Sal
Khan lives in California,
outside of San Francisco.
Sara Shadid, halfway
around the globe in Dubai.
Their lives are interconnected,
but Khan doesn't know it.
This is a story
about how one man
is helping to educate
the world, but has never
seen any of his
students face to face.
DAN SIMON: Where does
this passion come from?
SALMAN KHAN: I think I've
always enjoyed teaching.
DAN SIMON (NARRATING):
It's about a man who
gave up a lucrative
career in Silicon Valley
for what might look
like a boring desk job.
SALMAN KHAN: Right now,
I'm cash flow negative.
DAN SIMON (NARRATING): But
it was never about money.
And with his drive
and education,
Khan could have made millions.
He was valedictorian
of his high school,
with a perfect math
score on the SAT.
Then came MIT, Bill Clinton
handing him his diploma.
Next, Harvard Business School.
He was lured into hedge
funds and did well.
But Khan, who has a wife and
son to support, gave it up.
SALMAN KHAN: A lot of people
thought I was kind of crazy.
Obviously, when every
waking hour you have
you would sneak into a
room and make math videos
and put them on YouTube, people
kind of question what's up.
DAN SIMON (NARRATING):
Here's what's up --
Khan's YouTube videos.
SALMAN KHAN (ON YOUTUBE): Let's
do a couple more examples,
and I think you might get it.
DAN SIMON (NARRATING): They've
been clicked on more than 9
million times from
users around the world.
The topics range from math
to chemistry to economics.
SARA SHADID: From
every curriculum,
they can use the videos.
He's really helpful.
DAN SIMON (NARRATING):
One of his users,
19-year-old college sophomore
Sara Shadid in Dubai.
She says the videos
made all the difference
in helping her conquer calculus.
SARA SHADID: Before
each and every exam,
I take two days checking
all of his videos
and understanding the
small details he explains.
DAN SIMON: This
gigantic virtual school
originates from the
smallest of places,
from a tiny converted closet
inside Sal's master bedroom.
This is where he's able to
reach an estimated 80,000
knowledge-seeking users a month.
DAN SIMON (NARRATING): It
all started a few years ago
when a cousin wanted some
online math tutoring.
Pretty soon, other
relatives started
asking for similar help.
Suddenly, people he didn't
know started watching.
DAN SIMON: People must
have put in math terms,
and suddenly they find you.
SALMAN KHAN: Yeah, I think
that's just completely right.
It's that small
subset of people who
go to YouTube and do a
web search for greatest
common divisor.
DAN SIMON (NARRATING): People
did it, and it caught on.
It's now called
the Khan Academy.
The videos are short and simply
produced-- only his voice--
SALMAN KHAN (ON VIDEO): So
that's your slope of the--
DAN SIMON (NARRATING): With
a simple black background
and graphics.
SALMAN KHAN: There
are a lot of people
who need help with
math, science, whatever.
And I think they find
these YouTube videos
as kind of the ideal nuggets
to fill in their gaps.
DAN SIMON (NARRATING):
These mini classes
filled in Sara Shadid's gaps,
who says she and her friends
refer to Khan as the man
with the colored fonts.
Whatever you call
him or his teachings,
the success of his site
has validated that decision
to walk away from hedge funds.
Dan Simon, CNN, San Francisco.